imagine a scene of dialogue at a funeral
reception in one of the most
heartbreaking movies of its year does it
look something like this I'll get you
something hey your name oh never mind
forget it skip it what didn't what
that's probably not what you imagined
Manchester by the sea is a poignant
study of the impact of grief on its
characters lives there's a lot of great
things about this film but I want to
focus on how director Kenneth Lonergan
uses realism to frame the impact that
grief has on the characters spoilers
ahead
in a movie that primarily centered
around the impact of several deaths on
other people's lives there would be some
obvious scenes that you could use for
big emotional moments we see these all
the time in movies funerals in the rain
the wakes with poignant moments between
characters the dramatic deathbed scenes
those are all traditionally cinematic
moments but lonergan subverts cinematic
norms with his film during the moments
that would play in most films as
infinitely dramatic with teary close-ups
punctuated by soft lonergan chooses to
pull back he obscures dialogue with
music creates distance using slow-motion
[Music]
and disrupts with humor
[Music]
a perfect example of this is the scene
where Lee tells Patrick that his father
has died as the audience we know what's
happening but Lonergan doesn't let us
connect with the emotion of the scene he
forces us to watch from a distance
unable to hear what the characters are
saying and this tricks us into thinking
we're watching a moment that's more real
that hasn't been tampered with for
dramatic effect in our lives our
emotions don't follow a traditional act
structure they don't happen on cue with
the music huge events in our lives that
are supposed to be emotional and
foundational can also pass us by in a
blur and they might be shrouded in
dullness but those emotions can come
back to us in quiet moments in real life
grief doesn't end when the camera cuts
away from the big moments Manchester by
the seas cinematography reinforces this
most of the movie plays out with wide
shots but when we do get close-ups it's
during the everyday moments visit to a
lawyer's office a phone call actually me
because you off I just feel like a
little high a chance meeting on the
street or a moment alone and lonergan
purposefully disrupts our ideals of how
the larger moments should play leaning
away from making the story more dramatic
including things that normally would be
excluded from a film
these mistake annoyances and funny
moments are a part of real life they
don't stop when it's time to have a
funeral and when the movie doesn't focus
on the grief in the big moments like we
expect a movie to it feels less like a
movie and more like reality making the
characters grief feel all the more real
and when grief does hit the hardest
it often hits when we least expect it
[Laughter]
Lee's character is one who has
purposefully distanced himself from his
past in trying to distance himself from
his grief I think the idea was that you
would relocate relocate to Whitwell it's
near it should well as you can see your
brother worked everything out extremely
carefully oh thank you yes yes that this
movie shows us his journey back to
Manchester back among these people the
nonlinear storytelling illustrates how
this triggers his memories forcing him
to face his past and face his grief
again the constant shots of a landscape
and the setting of Manchester intercut
with the unveiling of the tragedy and
Lee's past helps us to understand how
his grief is connected to the location
in Manchester by the sea like in real
life grief doesn't obey the rules Greece
doesn't stop and start when it best
suits the next beat screenplay structure
Greece can sneak up on you returning
long after you want it to and sometimes
it's not there when it feels like it
should be where's my brother
please Josh go as you can see him if you
want Lee is unable to deal with his
creating a pattern of constant running
but those left in the wake of his
tragedy keep pulling him back forcing
him to face his past and his issues and
healing might be possible but it won't
be cinematic it won't come from a moment
like
this one but it might come from a moment
like this
[Music]